it's funny how simple that was I was  scared of it for years but all I needed  was to put myself back together and I  did I left  now their album the streets risking  exposure they're looking for me the  Cabal  I'm the enemy now the defector the  heretic I'm breaking a little dog and  they hate it but I don't think they can  follow me where I'm going it's against  their edicts look at these people  completely blind to the magic they just  live their lives  differently they knew what lies hidden  right in front of their faces  Wow calls this the crucible of fates I  just call it the tower it's been  whispering in my head for years  they say this place makes you face your  own fears your own demons but it can  also reveal your fate if you survived  the trials  my fate that's the only thing left to me  let's do this  you